warner bros india just released its
final tv spot and one thing that stuck
right out was a gigantic skeleton
of a dead godzilla in this scene kong
was seen putting out the battle axe from
the skull of this titanic titan
it's so big that even kong looked pale
in comparison it makes you wonder if
godzilla is still a
small kid just as kong was still in a
dawson in skull island
so might be the big g still be a small g
and given time and radiation he might
become as big as this one
and we will call this most of us
godzilla earth
titanic's gojira was 355 feet tall in
the 2014 movie
and grew to about 393 feet tall or 119
meters in king of the monsters
and now in godzilla vs kong he is just a
couple of feet taller and
at around 120 meters kong was 104 feet
tall in skull island
and after 50 years or so he is now 334
feet tall
or 102 meters it seems that these
monsters grow at an exponential rate in
between movies
still godzilla is the second tallest
after monster zero and kong is the
somewhere in the middle rankings behind
titan's behemoth and cilla
but taller than methuselah and the rest
but here in this hollow earth scene we
can see him pulling out the battle axe
from a skull that was way bigger than
anything we have ever seen till date
if you remember the scene of godzilla
and gong roaring at each other
in hong kong you would see that
godzilla's head is way smaller than that
of kong
but he is still 60 feet taller than the
big ape
godzilla is a reptilian tyrant that was
said to have been
around for millions of years but what if
that wasn't the case
what if they were talking about a
species of godzilla and not the
individual
i mean daegon was rumored to be the
father of the g-man and he died around
3000 years ago so could this be that
this individual
the skeleton was a very primal ancestor
of our beloved titan
so let us compare and estimate as to how
big this specimen could be
let's take this picture right here
godzilla and comb face to face
you could see that the skull of godzilla
is smaller than the head of kong and
kong could easily put his entire palm
on his face and here on this next image
we can see that the skull is edited to
be roughly as big as the one seen in the
opening scenes
of the tv spot forgive us this is
actually a t-rex skull but
we didn't really have a godzilla skull
to use but still it is
roughly the same size as long as gong's
arm from the fingers to the elbow of
course
now let's scale this thing up with the
image of godzilla as you can see if we
scale the size of the g-man in
accordance to the size of the skull
he would absolutely tower over kong
maybe as much as the size comparison
between kong from skull island and the
2014 godzilla
kong would barely even reach godzilla's
thick thighs
and if we stick one comb after another
to get the real height estimate then
it would take roughly three kongs at
full grown size to be equal with the
most of us godzilla earth
say gong is 234 feet tall as per the
official figures
then three times that would make this
monstrous specimen
around a thousand feet tall twice the
height of monster zero even
and cementing him as the biggest in his
universe we went back a bit to the first
trailer
the one with the hellhole scene kong was
seen standing on the top of a huge
godzilla-like ground with blue glowing
rocks
first we thought that this might just be
a coincidence and there's nothing much
to that but
now it would seem that the species
titanius gojira
is destined to outgrow everything else
in the most of us
this might even be the god of the hollow
earth the god of godzillas
and that was somehow killed by an axe
right through the skull by an ancestor
of kong
so if this big ass monster can be killed
so can a smaller present godzilla
so let's see this again it's so freaking
huge it might just
even be bigger or at par with godzilla
earth from the anime series
his remaining parts the ribs were big
enough to be half the size of a fully
grown gong
not to mention the disappeared dorsal
plates it's amazing dude
just amazing anyways gotta sleep and
watch the movie tomorrow
guess where i'm from india give us a
thumbs up for support and subscribe to
be a part of the minecube family
and smush smash that bell button to get
regular updates
on most of us and godzilla content right
here on minecube
take care fam